all right let's look at a few other
things that happened yesterday a George
Santos seemed to forget his own name on
the floor of the house multiple times
his name was called a four vote on
speaker of the house on the fifth ballot
he seems not to recognize uh his own
name which is just funny because of
course his his full name is George
Anthony devalder Santos and it raises a
question of whether does he even really
go by George Santos normally maybe he
goes by Anthony devalder or George
dewalder or Anthony Santos I don't know
but here he is they call him multiple
times doesn't seem to recognize they're
calling him for a vote the guy to his
right seems to tell him like Hey that's
your name sir
Santos
Santos
sarbanes okay and they move on to
sarbanes and then he held up his hand
and yells out that he's voting for
McCarthy
Jeffries
you even you even see Matt Gates come by
just kind of like what is it that is
even going on here
um so just kind of weird everything
about Santos is strange for all we know
he's used to being called some other
name I don't know and um it seems that
he is continuing to struggle to sort of
uh build community in the House of
Representatives and I don't really know
the end game for Santos I The First 48
hours are not sustainable running away
with a huge backpack running away from
reporters who want to ask him questions
sitting by himself in the floor of the
house picking his nose not recognizing
his own name and it's it's all just
truly bizarre but I also have kind of
like a morbid curiosity where like how
how awkward can this possibly get and
you all know I love awkward so we're
going ahead and gonna go ahead and
follow that and by the way the lies from
George Santos haven't stopped since he
arrived in Washington DC let's talk
about that next